c'est une première pour le groupe
automobile au losange son président
directeur général en a lui même fait
l'annoncé hier le constructeur français
s'associe au château de versailles et
devient mécène catherine pégard et
olives et jose sont venus vers nous pour
nous parler cette restauration du salon
de la paix et on nous en avons parlé
avec notre président avec monsieur ghosn
qui a trouvé que c'était une excellente
idée parce que renault et le château de
versailles font partie de l'inconscient
collectif des français on a voulu aller
au-delà d'un simple partenariat mais on
a sollicité donc renault pour un soutien
plus important est vrai mais senna
autour de ce salon de la paix et je
crois que pearl aux gones a voulu cette
association avec le château de
versailles puisqu'au fond c'est parler
de la création c'est parler de l'art de
vivre à la française c'est parler des
talents français
derrière cette oeuvre dolla furent
eliasson tout au bout de la guerre 10
des glaces se cache le salon de la paix
une réalisation de jules hardouin
mansart et charles le brun sa dernière
restauration date des années 1950 on va
nettoyer les marmots on va nettoyer les
bronzes on va nettoyer les stucs doré et
puis on va bien entendu restaurer les
peintures la restauration des peintures
a fait l'objet déjà de l'analyse très
poussé et nous savons que sous les
repeints du 20e siècle et du 19e on a à
peu près 80% de l'original de lebrun et
que cette originale de le brun va donc
nous allons essayer de le remettre à
jour c'est une restauration conservation
il ne s'agit absolument pas de
reconstituer de recréer mais de
retrouver d'être au plus près de
l'original le groupe automobile n'a pas
souhaité communiquer sur le montant de
ce mécénat le mécénat qui permet aussi
de bénéficier de réductions fiscales
pour les entreprises les travaux
débuteront au cours de l'année 2017 et
dureront 18 mois